got an official trailer number two for
disney and pixar's
soul i'm a soul man
too bad it's not going in theaters but i
don't know how people are gonna complain
about that this seems like a great movie
to watch at christmas at home with the
family
i don't know the legalities of what
they're doing of the release strategy is
it something you can like move on where
you gotta pay for it
this is something i would actually pay
for yeah without
being like skeptical or worrying about
it i would just be excited
and jamie foxx's work here is what
allowed him to get cass's electro
in disney spider-man movies let's do
this
disney pixar's seoul streaming on disney
plus december 25th
music is all i think about
[Music]
from the moment i wake up in the morning
to the moment i fall asleep at night
i was born
[Music]
[Music]
oh
where
are oh how neat
so we're pretty determined this is a
nature scenario
whoa
jumping out of the skyport that's for
sure
[Music]
impossibilities
all that stuff is in your body no smell
no taste or touch see
[Music]
okay
start crying is what's going to happen
[Music]
oh i feel the tears already
i feel my heart being warmed and the
fact that
we now have headphones for the
television that music is going to sound
amazing
it looks incredibly existential
wonderfully existential i was a little
bit confused
towards the latter part of it when
they're in this you know the soul
world uh essentially that is not hg
double hockey sticks i love about the
animation there
is it kind of reminds me of those like
philosophical
existential types of youtube videos that
you might have seen before
the sort of abstract doodle type people
yeah but it's like really cool animation
this looks like the pixar level of it
exactly it was just the utmost level of
detail yeah it looks great it looks it
looks wonderful towards the end where
you had those like paper thin
quality like just you know look they
look even more hand-drawn sketch there
yeah they seem
kind of like they're the villains of the
story so what i gather from this is
jamie foxx's character
is trying to get back into his body
or you know continue to live his life
and then there's
someone hunting him down going you can't
you can't inhabit that body
it's like nicolas cage just drive angry
exactly
that's what it is and then he's gonna
have to make a deal with the devil it's
gonna get really
dark at the i would actually i don't
think it would fit the movie that i'm
being advertised but i would love to see
that
turn out from the first trailer i really
got from that one
especially was the music that it was uh
showcasing how there's gonna be all this
wonderful
jazz in there and about feeling so much
of
soul you know encompasses like being in
tune with your feelings and allowing
yourself to feel
and here's the main theme that i got
this time around
what i think will bring me to tears you
know it encompasses love
yes but to put it plain and simple
gratitude
this ability to be appreciative and
grateful for the simplest of senses for
the immediacy of the moments you know a
lot of the little lines in here that
they have throughout the trailer
seem to really hone in on you know like
even that bit with the pizza which
i think was in the last trailer was it i
think so uh with the slapping around
you know how he's freaking out about
like i don't know taste or smell
yeah exactly for some reason slapping in
that same bit
onto if it is in the last year i think
it was slapping that same bit onto the
end of
this specific trailer made me think
about like the
the the existential quality of you know
like we have a limited time on this
earth
you might as well just learn to be in
the moment and really appreciate what
you have and pursue your passions what
really makes you feel alive what's the
difference between
living or surviving on this world as
opposed to actually living
yeah being alive versus living yeah and
i
i really picked up a lot on those
qualities on this specific trailer so
this is going to bring me to like
anything but usually it's not really
sad stuff can make me cry but really the
positive moving
loving acts are the things that will
really move me into tears yeah
those things that truly affirm some of
the more nuanced qualities of life and
yeah bring that sense of like
beauty yeah the kind of beauty that
moves you to tears yeah
yeah and i can definitely see that and i
think too that this movie at least from
the impression it's giving me could also
be very interesting in terms of just how
it's laid out from a traditional
standpoint because like you said
you have these two what appear to me
like opposing
presences who probably want to get him
and bring him back so their soul quota
can
you know be proper going into the
afterlife but i like the idea of a movie
that perhaps doesn't have a traditional
antagonist so much as it has you know
these different
realms and different lessons to come out
of them because i wonder if this will
too have to do with there's that line
about like can't crush a soul hero
that's what life earth is for and i
wonder if that's gonna come in two
as you know part of the fact that yeah
there are aspects of earth life that are
probably much harder and less idyllic
than this before realm but at the same
time again you know going to that theme
of gratitude
uh a lot of contrast comes out of that
too you know it's it's often times
the fact that you can weigh the
beautiful moments or the things that
make you feel alive like passion and
music and stuff like that against
the more difficult things this is what i
find so interesting about
this marketing um or just this movie so
far
is while it does look you know like
blissful
and family friendly and very cute it has
all those touches you'd expect out of a
disney animated movie what i
find is that it's kind of creating this
like
thought-provoking discussion at the same
time like i i've i haven't seen uh
i can't recall the last time there was
like pixar trailers maybe maybe coco
where
people were talking like thematically
what it might deal with
and lessons to be learned from there i
mean we all know pixar is like the
powerhouse when it comes
to this level of animation and such and
their storytelling yet
for this specific one i think because
you're dealing directly with a a
character who is
dying or is dead i'm not sure what
you're dealing with what the rules are
all right i don't know yeah i don't know
exactly what it is from the first year i
thought he was dead
and then yeah here it made it seem like
he's caught in some kind of purgatory or
in the
afterlife and and this tina fey
character i'm under the impression
she's the b story of this but somehow
she will be the
ultimate heart of it you know the thing
that but she'll probably be the
character that really moves this or
she'll just be funny you know but i
imagine she'll actually be the
the former uh of it i think this is like
a wonderful way to spend christmas
watching this yeah it might not take
place at christmas but there's something
about it that feels christmasy and i'm
also wondering if it might deal with the
idea
of like following your passion choosing
your own paths because they have this
set up i don't know how much you're
going to delve into it but like you get
this personality trait
so as opposed to like that nature versus
nurture discussion i don't know how much
of that will be
present in here but it'd be kind of cool
if they explored that yeah hopefully i
mean because i think that it represents
some of
what people love the most about pixar is
their ability to make these things that
look obviously very beautiful and fun
but that also touch
on some real gristle of life yeah that's
hard to deal with for anybody and i
think it's important that they make
these movies that
like this really appeals to me because
this is a family movie ostensibly that
doesn't feel like it's aimed directly at
kids
and it reminded me yeah they better not
be pointing kinds of kids in this group
you know there's a common misconception
that animation is for kids and it's not
it's it's for everybody and i think that
this is a movie that has an obvious
kid appeal but that really does seem
like it could speak on all
levels to all ages and that's something
that makes pixar movies
so magical when they're great and i
think christmas is a perfect time partly
because with
less christmas trappings on display this
kind of does remind me of something that
wouldn't
be too far out of line with like an it's
a wonderful life or something like that
you know dealing with
the nature of life but also the desire
and the drive to
live seem like things to address around
you know the whole
season especially in a way like this
suggests that we'll be heartwarming and
fun as well as
touching and deep you know i disagree
entirely
john dreamworks just give me celebrity
voices
so let's bring it on subscribe what do
you guys think about this trailer
you're gonna be spending christmas
watching this leave your thoughts down
below
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell last but not least
i'd like to shout out a man named jean
jeter today i was thinking about
which one of our patronage has a an
enriching
soul and really puts it on display at
every corner
i'd say most of them but today i chose
you gene you won the lottery buddy
right well done gene is kicking so much
buttocks over on his channel and
managing to be
wildly creative and explore i really
feel like he's someone who explores the
soul a lot through his artistic work
whether that be something funny or
dramatic heavy or light he explores all
colors
of the world and i really appreciate all
the hard work you're doing and all the
art that you put out buddy so keep being
you brother
hope to see you one day we haven't seen
each other ever hope to meet you one day
somewhere outside of the instagrams